okay
hi everyone so for people joining this
live stream this
is a design review about calculus and
algebra functionality
for the upcoming version of wolfram
language and um
i think we have um looked at some of
this already
and there's some new stuff to look at
here is that right roger
um yeah it's the same stuff i think we
didn't look
at everything and we need to settle the
names at the top we need to
if you go down past special functions to
the algebra section
we have adam here today too we can
discuss cylindrical formula which we
didn't get to
last time the other two items
are are not making it probably
and there will be no design changes
anyway the minimize maximize
that's a pity okay they're just i mean
they're just
yes we will see you in okay
they'll make it eventually but maybe not
this release
so did we look at asymptotic expectation
and so on yet
i think you just glanced over it but but
we can look at that
okay
all right
let's look at this first
all right what is this
it's a representation for
for the cylindrical algebraic formula so
it is a presentation for for the result
of computing cylindrical decomposition
so that it can be used in
in other computations and the
computations know that
the input is a synthetic formula because
it's after after you
make a boolean formula out of it you
cannot
you can't really tell that it's a
serious okay so cylindrical
decomposition
normally will just give this kind of
form
right yes yes that is a decomposition in
terms of
what is it the semi-algebraic sets or
something yeah so it's the composition
of semi-algebraic sets
in terms into into cells that are
bounded by algebraic functions
but that decomposition satisfy certain
strict contracts
for it to be a such decomposition
so it needs to be cylindrical meaning
that the variables that occur
at the bounds to get back that even that
first example shows that that
the bounds include variables that are
previous variables so the bounds include
x okay so what can generate a
cylindrical formula
only these guys it's cylindrical formula
so cylindrical formula is
an input creates it and represents it
okay and what and what functions eat it
uh reduce resolve find instance solve
optimization functions
and everything there i guess and
everything
itself yeah but also everything that
indirectly uses like the geometry
functionality
the if you integrate over piecewise bool
things
okay so what is it in the sense that
you know does it have tentacles hanging
out which are its variables or is it
just
a how should i think about this object
it's it's a formula so it's so the
variables are outside so you see that
it's a formula in variables that are
listed later
which means that it's true or false if
you give numeric values to those
it will be true or false stephen if you
give why on earth aren't you calling
this
cylindrical formula function putting the
variables
first and having it walk and talk like a
function
because it's the primary goal isn't to
evaluate it to true false the primary
goal is to
like if you do boolean operations on it
if if you have those things coming in
you can do more operations on it
no i understand that i understand that
but i mean so it doesn't have to be the
variable so so the synthetic
formula object is itself is it's a
boolean function so the second argument
can contain any any expressions in it so
instead of xyz it could be
x square y minus one z plus seven
what does it mean then if this
that but then if you feed it specific
arguments there
that will be what what will those
specific arguments be
if if you replace in the result if you
replace xyz with
with specific arguments you get true or
false
i'm confused look yeah i think that
i think adam so adam meant that in the
in the formula when you get the
cylindrical formula the argument's there
you can use formulas for the x y
but what about here if i do this no no
no no no it's
yeah that's what i think those are just
is the constructor
so this is the constructor the input for
the input format that constructs
individual formula right once you have
cylindrical formula the cylinder
from the object is right but so the way
i should think about this
is if i say reduce x equals x i get true
and i don't understand why this thing
isn't
uh cylindrical
decomposition function
x y z x square blah blah blah blah blah
well it doesn't need x y z after after
it's done
i mean after it's done cylindrical
formula object doesn't contain any
variables anymore
the variables are outside they have been
given to
to the input to construct cylindrical
formula so synthetic
formula okay so it's a function okay
i see i see
but that would be fine i mean in this
case here
the return value here could be something
that is just like
an opaque function object that then just
gets applied to things
right that's just that's what synthetic
formulas no no i understand that but so
what i'm saying is
that i'm claiming the correct name is
cylindrical decomposition function
because it is it is a function now the
fact that it
processes itself to not contain this
literal stuff inside
is its business but it acts like a
cylindrical decomposition function does
it not
yes afterwards or it actually so
so it gives you now it's not quite the
same see
you you input the cylindrical formula
with x y z and you get the x y z on the
outside
you don't have to apply it you get the
original variables
so you get the cylindrical formula which
is a that's really weird
your function that's really weird that's
really weird
it's really convenient if you look at
the example how it works in the
workforce so it's just
you know it produces the formula you
don't really want to get a pure function
and then you have to apply to it
to something
what the heck is this what the heck is
this
no come on this can't work like this
look if there's either f of x y here
you can't just say f well f is f
is an expression somewhere
oh it has the oh my god this is so
freaking confusing
roger i don't think this is right i
don't think this is right
i don't think it's right i think it's
scrambled
yeah well so
we have to
i think that once we see more use cases
it's easier to accept
but we do need these efficient
representations
that may be but i don't think this is
correctly designed
yeah i so let's let's go through what
the design has to achieve
okay what you're trying to do is
you want to have if i could just write
for you a thing that said
tag of this polynomial
would you be happy or are you actually
processing the innards of that
synological formula
it's it's it's processing so it's it
it's it doesn't contain the polynomial
anymore
you can look at the input form it's
complicated but it doesn't have
this is the process you know it's
computed seriously composition
this is the process this is even more
bizarre
i can't even only ask what that is
it's something that's specifically put
there so that you don't edit it and
exactly
expect it to work because there's a bit
of a hack tower here so okay
so i'm just trying to understand here so
this thing stands in for a boolean
expression involving polynomials correct
or involving algebraic functions
that is its role yes and it stands for
for a specifically formatted expression
that has
certain properties that are not easy to
check so if you get an expression
oh yeah i i get all of that but i'm
trying to understand what it
is okay so let's get an analogy so i
mean
let's say we have an algebraic number
or a root object boolean function is the
design analogy to this
okay if you look at the boolean function
object
all right but here
if i take one of those things well okay
let's look at pulling function
notice it does have the word function in
its name
because it really is a function i know
that's the difference i know i know i
know i know i know i know i know you
apply it to arguments
and it does its thing right and
um actually you can also
apply to the confirmatory arguments and
does this thing so it's very
similar i know i understand i got it
yeah i got it and it's true or false
yes
this is totally freaking weird and we've
never done it this way anywhere else
of having something turn into a
function of arguments that were inside
it
now having said we've never done
anything like that before i i think
maybe there's a counter example
no but if you do f there instead of f x
the second argument
no i was trying to do something
different here let me try and do this
that's not a good example either
but you see the f of x if i could do
this with an interpolating function
let's see what happens with nd solve
it behaves the same way now but what
does it do what
does it put an interpolating function
does it have
yeah when you have f of x you get
interpolating function of x
yeah that's what i thought which is
behaves the same way the cylindrical
thing does
oops
okay you got a precedent here
this is a precedent right what this is
doing
yes okay
but i think boolean function does that
too doesn't it
yeah no no it doesn't do it it doesn't
need to do it
they're a variable case if you do the
last one with
form i think you will get something with
no no dude you you get that but you
don't get
a raw boolean function look at the
example
that's at the bottom
function yeah i guess let's pull in
convert
right so the
so you know it's sort of a pity then
that cylindrical decomposition
can't return one of these objects
yes which except that it's used already
and i know i know i know i know i know
so one of the principles of design is
figure out what the right right design
is first
and then see if we can make a bridge
from what we're currently doing to that
correct design
okay so imagine that we could rewrite
cylindrical decomposition
what would we want it to do
okay imagine just imagine that we had a
function called cylindrical algebraic
decomposition
just for fun we did i know
just for fun let's imagine we had such
function
and that then it could return different
values than our current cylindrical
decomposition function
and it could return
a
you know cylindrical algebraic function
okay
just imagine that's how it worked would
that make sense
yeah that would make sense
but we will still need the page to
document this format
the cylindrical formula whatever the
name it is
absolutely but but what i'm suggesting
then
is that you know given that we think we
would much prefer
to return
um boy it's been around a while
to return
is that the right names the logical
algebraic function would that be the
correct name for this thing
it's usually called formula because it's
boolean values
[Music]
no i don't care i mean it's just like
it's a boolean formula too but we still
call it boolean function
because it acts as a function yeah yeah
so so i guess for
from this point we have we function but
i mean the question is
to me
is there any other design change we
might like to make to synological
decomposition
i mean in its formula output is also
useful so it's
like both outputs are useful for
different things
well i mean one is the normal of the
other right
one is normal there or the other right
now yeah
all right so what you were trying to do
oh boy roger help me out here yeah
so if we do that if we modify
cylindrical decomposition we need an
argument that says format which we could
do so it went down that
it's a possibility except we added in
these topological operations
and if it just been yeah okay
so where else would you put them i mean
imagine you were renaming the things so
it's called cylindrical algebraic
decomposition so all current designs
are off the table well that's what i'm
saying
imagine we would still have this
topological problem actually okay
so explain what what are these
topological things
they give you um
other outputs basically they give you
the boundary output
the closure of the input set yeah so why
i don't understand why you're not just
calling it boundary formula
or boundary
boundary expression and then boundary
as the you know you could do something
like that
where this is the case that corresponds
to the actual explicit expression
and the other one is you know i mean it
might even be boundary expression
boundary function
well we i guess we could name this the
second thing to not be i mean it is
called op
but it doesn't have to be topological
operation it just says just it just says
what the
what the format is oh yeah what it
computes
and and part of that we just then need
to come up with a name
for um well what i'm suggesting here is
that there are two cases
boundary expression boundary function
right but
normally it comes up with something
that's equivalent to input which is
which is the same we just need a name
for that what do you mean
expression expression function without
anything expression and function i guess
yeah that'd be fine yeah and so then
that's actually not a bad solution you
know even for cylinder you're just using
that for cylindrical decomposition
extending that re-document
up a little bit um
and that says what you get and then we
just double the length of that list
so it's instead of
algebraic function would be would be a
new new symbol that just gets generated
by synthetic
the composition yes
does it make any sense to call it
cylindrical function or is that stupid
function i mean did we misname
cylindrical decomposition because
it's usually
i have to say my suspicion is that we
should re-document cylindrical
decomposition of cylindrical algebraic
decomposition
have it by default return cylindrical
algebraic functions
and just sort of say this has been super
cylindrical decomposition has been
superseded
i don't know i mean maybe that's silly i
just feel like cylindrical decomposition
hasn't exactly been used
you know it's used internally a lot but
i doubt it's that much
used in the outside world um
it is used so i i i okay well fine i
mean
that name it's going to get supported
forever but the question is whether the
default
i don't think we need to rename it
stephen we can we can upgrade the design
of it
to accommodate this okay but then what
are we going to call the function
version whatever we want
cylindrical function is is kind of okay
algebraic function
is actually with the algebraic inside
that look better
yeah but then we can't have cylindrical
decomposition why not
algebraic function well i think we'd
have to call it cylindrical
decomposition function
we could have cynical decomposition
function
all right so then then the the decision
is cylindrical decomposition by default
still gives an expression
but cylindrical decomposition with
second with third argument function
returns a cylindrical decomposition
function
okay and that cylindrical decomposition
function
has like a classifier function or
something
has no documented internal form it's
just an opaque thing
that eats arguments
and gets you know and gives results
right
right yeah yeah we can document it as
being constructed by cylindrical
decomposition so we undocument its own
construction and then the the examples
for
for use of it go to the page of cynical
decomposition
yes no i mean you can
we can because you can still have
examples that use this cylindrical
decomposition that
that generated
on the page of cylindrical function yes
yes
then the quality composition function
function
okay all right i think we nailed this
one okay
do i have to look at the solve thing
with taking assumptions is that is that
controversial or not
no not particularly
i'd always thought i thought it had
taken assumptions for like a decade
um
oh i there's something wrong with the
call box
we have to fix that i don't know how you
made it but
okay okay the indentation is wrong yes
okay fine i'll check that
it's very weird to me that you have to
have an asymptotic everything
i mean i admit that it is it's almost
like it's a decorator of
asymptotic of expectation
yeah but we built okay so the
alternative solution that we have which
i
but i really think that these guys
deserve it both expectation and
probability
and what we did for integral transforms
is those are part we didn't build
asymptotic
laplace transform and asymptotic inverse
laplace transform
and and the other 30 such functions
but what what you use is asymptotic of
inactive
of that form
yeah it's not the best solution no
i mean i think a better solution would
be something that
says um
let's imagine okay
you can do that but oh
no what are you doing
no no
why not
i mean possibly this isn't a good idea
but just explain why
so this is instead of you know this is
the equivalent then
for laplace transform we can have all
other transforms
basically is what you intend yeah yeah
it'll plus anything i mean this would be
you could put anything in there you
could put an integral in there if you
wanted to
why oh no no it doesn't relate to the t
and an s
no it doesn't i'm not saying that i'm
saying this
okay there right it's saying
this is an integral but it's saying
this is a modifier of the integral
that looks worse than asymptotic of
something that you know well except you
have to use an active in the asymptotic
well you can also avoid using it but
then you're going to pay the cost of
trying to solve it exactly first
devendra was going to say something yeah
i'm just going to say that just like if
we did
n office uh d so you get nd solve d
solve failed
so the asymptotic is a wrapper for all
these functions
i know so i think that that seems to
have worked
very very quickly yeah okay but
nevertheless you're trying to introduce
particular asymptotic x
functions we just these are the last
ones we think are are
worth it because i think that these both
expectation and probability
are high traffic solvers
um
and they can benefit from the specific
analysis done to them
yes because a lot of the asymptotics is
actually developed for just probability
and statistics all right okay so let's
take a look at this one
by the way i wouldn't use dot dot dot
there like it'll confuse the um
i would use you know var tilde tilde
dist there i think it'll confuse the
syntax
uh system if you do that okay
okay nice enough
asymptotic problems it's just a kind of
weird name asymptotic probability to
suggest it's a markov chain and it's
been running for a long time
and what's its asymptotic probability
i that doesn't suggest that to me
by the way i assume you have the spell
checker turned on when you're offering
these pages
i'm sorry i'll just check that sorry
yeah no no i'm just i'm just saying yes
yes yes
yes
okay
okay so i think we did we look at these
do we need to look at these
we did look at them and uh
um all right let's go back to these
horrors
okay so i think what we've agreed is
that this will be function injective
is that right that was from yesterday so
i don't think the people here have heard
that yet
so it goes along with function
discontinuities function metamorphic etc
etc
is commenting that that asymptotes are
underrated and that
um ever since newton they seem to have
been underrated
i agree but do we have asymptotes here
anywhere
no no
i mean you asymptotes are usually in
in visualization functions yeah and
establish you can compute the asymptotes
of a function
yeah that's
i mean we have it listed as an
application example for asymptotics you
divide it by x
all right well so if we're if we're okay
with function injective
function analytic function metamorphic
function discontinuities function
singularities
those all seem reasonable um
now there's this strictness thing what
does that mean again
so it requires strict strictly monotonic
or strictly positive
instead of with people's difference
non-decreasing
um
what do we think about different names
for this
strict condition
you can't say strictness arrow true or
false
i think strict condition is okay
unlikely to be clobbering something else
um
does it make i mean it's like
it's like a strictly applied condition
is the full thing that you're doing
no no it uses strict inequalities
instead of
non-restrictive inequalities say it
again
uses strict inequalities instead of
non-strict inequalities
well why don't we say that
why don't we just call it that then we'd
know what it was and i wouldn't have to
ask the question
right
strict inequality singular or strict
inequalities plural
such inequalities plural i think is
right
sounds good to me okay this leaves over
then polynomial expression q
okay what's the difference in latin
polynomial q
it's a so polynomial q is sometimes
trying to figure out it it's using right
inputs to to convert the expression to
something like watch nothing
it's using rat input the internal thing
that we have for
foreign it's a kelly roach production
that's trying to recognize
um like like trigonometric
polynomials as polynomials right
actually i think it works only for
exponentials
maybe yes oh i remember that
okay um that means that it's
um well it's potentially slow and
gives you a surprise so why isn't it
being given a performance goal
well it's not really about performance
but about the
you know performance build should not
make make the output
different like true instead of false or
vice versa
um
i think it should be an option to
polynomial cue i think you you're
you know you're sliding down a slippery
slope of of you know the 17 ways
something could be or not be a
polynomial
right so this was sort of
functional accompanying rational
expression q which
which is the new thing because we don't
have a rational function cure whatever
we call like
you know analog of polynomials so
rational expression
will do this syntactic this is a mess
okay let's let's call a spade a spade
basically polynomial q a reasonable
function
you say has the wrong functionality
so you're introducing polynomial
expression q rational expression q
would be an okay name for a rational
expression
or rational function i mean would it be
called would it normally if it wasn't
for these other constraints would you
call it rational function q
probably rational expression so rational
functioning you might
might expect that you decide whether
something is an
actual rational function even if it's
not written as a rational function
and this is
oh okay that's a decent argument
no you you can't use the if if you're
gonna
give this argument the first line of the
usage says gives true of expert
is structurally a has
structurally the form of a polynomial in
x
is an expression that is structurally a
polynomial in x
yeah we could write that up there it
should it should definitely say it
somewhere
yeah i would put it there because that
way it explains why it isn't polynomial
q
we can do that and polynomial q should
say
and this doesn't even have a c also to
polynomial q which it should
right obviously i don't think that's
good
so fine so this is a structure okay i
i'm i'm i'm
reluctantly recanting on this but it
will be nice to understand what
polynomial q's precise contract
is it's we we would like to that too
we are mystified well look at the code
well
so it's it's it's like putting on your
expression except that it uses
that input and then you have to explain
what that input does
exactly it's fascinating right input
though i can tell you
it's ratting out the expression one
thing stephen i think
kelly roach must have been a physicist
because
no no because i wrote some functionality
that i realized it was somehow hidden in
rat input
but it would be super super hard to get
to and
when i looked at the source code tried
to understand what the heck was going on
he used bosons and other things fermions
and bosons to explain
what's going on in code
well i can't so i was thinking
that it's like what
i can't explain that
um
okay
um
all right i'm i'm now trying to answer
that question actually
of um
huh that's right i remember what is his
it was interesting computational
linguistics
right okay oh no did i send you down a
physics hole
no no i'm just answering the question
was that developer a
physicist and the answer is no okay
okay uh right well what else do we have
to figure out here
i think that that concludes it could you
take
one scan all the way down just yep
this is all lovely but i don't think
there's anything for me here
no no and well i see those are just new
pages
yeah yeah they will go you know
if you have a heuristic for
understanding when do i use trig expand
trigger reduce
trig uh factor
i would that would be wonderful
yeah that's that's back to the same rat
input actually
all these functions uh you know the rats
that
are uh you know running onto the ship
so to speak yes
um okay great
um
do i should i just look for for fun at
one la may function just to admire it
some it's that we finally got this
does it have any kind of weird order
conventions like um
uh like jacobi elliptics do and things
um all in sense of
i mean they're the the odd and even lame
functions
so the second argument over there is uh
kind of order even and then you get
different behavior
if that's what you're asking
no it's not what i've asked i'm asking
there are different argument conventions
right for what um
for what this means sn z vertical bar m
right there aren't there different ways
of writing the arguments using
isn't that what the um what's it called
jacobi amplitude or something
converts between them right right i
don't think there's right away
i mean the only thing that did affect us
is should use an m or k
because you could either write your
elliptics in terms of m or k and they're
using m
for consistency okay but i mean so but
the k means something different from the
m is that correct
yes exactly it's like roughly like a
square root kind of thing you know so
you have to document that
i don't see that documented here okay
also sparrow conal is really a thing you
better
get it put in the spelling corrector
okay fine
i mean does it have a hyphen or was that
hyphen
only from 100 years ago no we checked uh
dlmf the digital library that's where we
got this one from so i think it's okay
but
i can still check again i would i would
look
look there are two choices either it's
spelled right in which case it should be
an aspelling corrector yes
yes well okay so i'm seeing on the web
lots of
i'm not seeing a very convincing story
here but spheroconal is written without
a
yes so it's written often without the
the um
hyphen and i would remove the hyphens
okay words that start hyphenated and
unhyphenated 25 to 50 years later okay
um
so we converging to german
i don't know um
anyway uh
so you're saying the the new is an
integer
the second argument j uh is an integer
and if j is odd you might get behave
like let's say cosine and
if j is even then it gets signed like so
so
it's like the elliptic patterns i mean
it's it's that kind of pic
pick a number but it's got to be in this
set or it's an arbitrary integer
um it could either be order even it's a
bit like elliptic theta but if you
didn't do this and you'd have
four kinds of lame functions you'd have
la messi
why is the argument order the way you're
writing it uh
i'm not sure we had we i don't we didn't
see this at any place
but maybe just uh this question how will
types it
uh so no no no no no i'm asking the
question usually
when there's a kind of major switching
parameter
it comes first okay
i mean in other words i don't know
you've got to look at how
people write lemay functions um
i mean why don't i see the main function
ecj new okay so the convention
if that's how it's written i believe
that is the convention we use that the
subscript comes first
yes exactly and so people don't even use
even or i mean they always separate them
out
but we are trying to combine them to
follow so so we've invented that
idea of putting the superscript with the
j
is that correct yes yes but what does
this
see in the s if isn't s the sign like
and c
the cosine like no it would you'd think
that but they just correspond different
x values
so let me see corresponds to eigen value
let me eigen value a and
let me s called eigen value b and then
within c and s you still have
a kind of bifurcation of sine like and
cosine like behavior
so it's not like this
what happens to all our numeric function
things when you have that weird second
argument that has to be an integer
so how it behaves with n values you mean
or yes
i think that has to be custom done yeah
in that case
yes to to prevent that
you know brian is making an interesting
suggestion on a live stream that we
should have a link to mathworld for
background on these concepts i'm not
sure how often we do that
i think we started off actually building
background things actually
eric who built mathworld also built a
bunch of those background things
but the idea of just linking straight to
background articles in math world why
haven't we done that
i thought we had done that there was
like systematic
um okay well maybe so
but the question is how we keep it up
because i think that might have been
part of a
a linking project um a crosslands
project
yeah well okay so that that is worth
asking then
of brian and the um uh brian
v um yeah so if you look at sign
for instance there's a link to math
world and the function site
okay okay fine so the the question is i
mean
that that was done in the crosslinks
project but the crosslinks project was
ended because we
finished all the cross-linking right i'm
not sure if that process was correctly
continued
that's exactly what i was thinking too
we probably have to ask
ask the new docs group it's still called
new docs in the same way that
that it's called new pence in england
the currency even though it's been like
that for
whatever 50 years
okay
um i i mean i would check what happens
with the numeric thing
we're putting that thing second yeah we
should i'm not certain
okay i'll check that uh
okay um
looking good okay off we go then that i
think this is some
um let's declare victory look forward to
seeing this stuff migrate from prototype
to
to the main build thank you very much
thank you steven